you were actually on the Johnny Carson
show you got you were one of those
comedians that I guess it was after
Saturday Night Live but was it before
what was read Fred when did he retire oh
[ __ ] - I don't know because I did it two
months before he retired Wow
so whenever that was so maybe you were
already on Saturday Night Live we were
tired in May of 92 okay thanks Benji all
right yeah I had to go out and I got the
spot and the talent guy goes when you go
out there you hit the mark you do your
[ __ ] crummy jokes and you come right
back because now what do you said just
come on just do it and I go I heard
Johnny waves you over if you're really
good it's not gonna happen I wouldn't
worry about that just do your [ __ ] come
back come right to me like a puppy you
know come on come here
like he's right into the curtains show
so [ __ ] uptime I've never even dives
like sure meanwhile went out there and
[ __ ] a [ __ ] brick because you don't
even realize you're looking at cameras
it's different than you see on TV so all
your mind does is go right to that like
oh my God look at these cameras the
floor so shiny you start to look around
and see how artificial it all when I go
it's so small in here yeah wait am i
doing my act like I was like I don't
have to do [ __ ] so anyway I see little X
got it found the X look back thumbs up
guys I got a rookie and then Carson's a
little behind you to the right so right
because you can't really look at him do
you remember your act from what you did
I think I go hey I got a new car
it's a UPS truck I actually just got a
second park wherever I want and did that
did that get some laughs oh yeah not
like it just died it actually did
welcome good crowd right so then anyway
I did a couple of those and then a
couple zingers threw in a few doozies
and then I finished but I did pretty
good yeah so I look to the right and
wave but I can't even see him because I
don't look all the way to the right and
use it Martin Short and they cut the
Martin Short they go he was great more
nervous yeah I get him over here he goes
yeah come here
and Johnny waves me over and I turn and
leave
and he goes what what's he doing he
doesn't he doesn't okay he's not coming
over alright he just left
okay Davis I gotta go back I gotta go
back and watch the agent weird so then I
get back anything drunk I know vodka why
do you know anyway alright
[ __ ] you you told me don't even look at
the guy yeah you were in the mindset
that like you just had a return to the
back of the stage it was not an option
that you were told to return like a dog
I get backstage and then they knock on
the door had my shirt off right it was
like a frickin BO blowout like blowing
down the trees like during a hurricane
and I open the door I go what I'm my
shirt off holding a jug of pepto-bismol
Johnny Doc and Martin Short oh my
goodness
can I go holy [ __ ] and Johnny goes hey
ed you ran off I just want to say good
job you were funny I kind of froze and
then he looks at my pepto-bismol go I'm
trying to quit the stuff I was sorry I
was nervous you guys hey me too
and then he left and that was it